[Musik]
china reich der mitte
eine wirtschaftliche weltmacht die sich
nicht nur durch ihre weitreichende
kultur sondern auch durch ihre
zukunftsweisende technologie präsentiert
in vielen bereichen der industrie ist
china eines der führenden länder doch
nicht für alle neuen technologien
scheint das land offen zu sein die
krypto industrie mit ihren männern ist
der wirtschaftsmacht ein dorn im auge
china hat alle crypto transaktion
verboten und auch angekündigt dass
mining von digitalen vermögenswerten zu
unterbinden der bisher herzte schlag
gegen die branche
[Musik]
die volksrepublik china ist nicht
begeistert wenn es um die stars in der
krypto währung geht und gerade die
nummer eins bitcoin hat seit seiner
erfindung mit china einen langen
intensiven disput hinter sich der handel
der ältesten crypto währung der welt ist
in der volksrepublik china nicht gern
gesehen und das nachdem china bitcoin
erst zu seinem heutigen ruhm verholfen
hat schließlich haben wir es den
zahlreichen pionieren und männern aus
china zu verdanken dass länder wie el
salvador oder venezuela bitcoin als
alternative zahlungsmittel anbieten
dennoch ist die ablehnende haltung der
chinesischen regierung gegenüber der
krypto währung im laufe der zeit immer
deutlicher und schärfer geworden aber
die chinesischen behörden gehen hier
noch weiter um den crypto handel zu
unterbinden crypto transaktionen werden
als illegale finanzaktivitäten
betrachtet einschließlich der von
offshore börsen angebotenen
dienstleistungen so die people's bank of
china auf ihrer website sie fügte hinzu
dass crypto währungen einschließlich
bitcoin und tessa keine realen fiat
währungen sind und somit nicht in umlauf
gebracht werden können der bitcoin brach
nach der ankündigung ein und fiel um 8
prozent auf etwa 43.000 us-dollar betrug
geldwäsche und übermäßiger
energieverbrauch werden mit crypto
währung in verbindung gebracht der
enorme energieverbrauch des crypto
mannings ist auch ein grund dafür dass
die gesamte crypto branche unter die
lupe genommen wird die chinesische
wirtschaft planungsbehörde erklärte dass
es ihre aufgabe sei hart durchzugreifen
und das crypto mining zu unterbinden um
die gesetzten klimaziele der regierung
nicht zu gefährden
china sieht sich mit einer schweren
energiekrise konfrontiert die bereits
rohstoffe wie aluminium oder stahl in
mitleidenschaft gezogen hat das land
beherbergt fast 50 prozent der
weltweiten crypto meiner und hatte einen
anteil von 46 prozent der globalen hedge
raid einem maß für die beim mining und
der verarbeitung verwendeten
rechenleistung wird bitcoin und die
krippe industrie sich auch ohne china
durchsetzen können was sagen analysten
und expertinnen zu den jüngsten
entwicklungen in china
kommen wir nun zu china es sieht so aus
als ob sie es dieses mal ernst meinen
sie verschärfen stark die sanktionen
gegenüber crypto währungen die psi
erklärt auf ihrer website dass sie alle
transaktionen verbieten bzw alle crypto
transaktionen nun illegal sind
der bitkom großfeld in diesem moment
unter 44.000 sogar 43.000
sprechen wir dazu mit unserer krypta
expertin in asien joana was können wir
nun von diesem schritt erwarten
es klingt so als ob alles außer das
halten von club boss nun illegal ist ist
das richtig
hallo matt es sieht ganz so aus aber die
frage bei solchen regulierung ist ja
immer was bedeutet das in der praxis wie
sie wissen hat china im laufe der jahre
schon mehrfach versucht hart
durchzugreifen
aber die menschen haben es geschafft die
maßnahmen zu umgehen und sind zum
beispiel auf andere börsen ausgewichen
es gibt immer noch eine menge leute die
krypto währungen halten und ich denke
wir werden keinen besonders großen
rückgang von bitcoin oder einen
allgemeinen rückgang von krupp doch
sehen was wir bisher gesehen haben ist
für crypto eigentlich kein großes
problem es ist also keine große
überraschung für den markt allerdings
wird es auch nicht gerade die preise
steigen lassen das ist richtig
johanna warum passiert das gerade jetzt
gab es hierfür ein auslöser ist es
vielleicht nur ein ablenkungsmanöver um
von der momentane wagram krise
abzulenken
[Musik]
sie beobachten natürlich wie andere
regulierungsbehörden wie zum beispiel
die ssc in den usa hier schritte
unternimmt und versucht ebenfalls hart
durchzugreifen
aber china hat die dinge schon immer auf
seine eigene art geregelt es ist
natürlich möglich dass sie versuchen den
fokus auf eva brand abzuschwächen aber
china könnte die krypta industrie als
ganzes betrachtet und sagen es ist an
der zeit etwas zu tun und das könnten
sie natürlich auch schon beschlossen
haben bevor er wie brandt großer
aufmerksamkeit erregte
besteht die gefahr dass kleinanleger bei
spekulationen mit diesen vermögenswerten
auf der strecke bleiben oder werden
wohlhabende chinesen es als chance
nutzen um ihr vermögen ins ausland zu
verlagern
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich ist es etwas von beiden
und wie gesagt ich weiß es nicht aus
erster hand aber es gibt natürlich
spekulationen diese richtung aber bei
all den spekulationen sollte man im auge
behalten dass der von vielen als
indikator für den fluss von crypto
währungen aus china angesehen wird 99
prozent seines preises also ungefähr 1
dollar gehalten hat und das ist sehr
interessant
kommen wir nun direkt zur die wanderwelt
unserem großen crypto beobachter und
blumberg live strategen also eher die
erst einmal guten morgen wir versuchen
hier herauszufinden wie weit die sache
noch gehen wird richtig china hatte den
bitkom ja bereits den krieg erklärt und
dies scheint nun ein weiterer schritt in
richtung eines vollständigen verbots zu
sein
also wenn sie wirklich keine
transaktionen mehr zulassen fühlt es
sich schon sehr nach eskalation an aber
was heißt das genau bedeutet es ich kann
keine kryptisch mehr kaufen oder
bedeutet es dass ich generell keine
transaktionen mehr durchführen kann kann
ich keine bitcoins mehr von meinem
telefon aus verschicken oder an einer
börse damit handeln ich bin mir immer
noch nicht ganz im klaren darüber was
das genau bedeutet und was transaktion
unter diesen besonderen umständen
bedeutet aber china macht jetzt also
ernst und bitkom ist im moment noch aus
china und chinesische investoren
angewiesen es gibt sehr viele
chinesische investoren die bitcoin seit
langem nutzen und es mit aufgebaut haben
wir werden sehen wie sehr die krypto
preise auf dieser verschärfung reagieren
interessant francine spricht hier einen
wichtigen punkt an dieses schrittweise
vorgehen erst haben sie club börsen
verboten
das mining und jetzt sieht es so aus als
ob alle crypto bezogenen transaktionen
illegal sind
für mich bedeutet dass jede transaktion
abhandeln kaufen dienstleistungen oder
zwischen freunden verschicken völlig
egal absolut jede art von crypto
bezogenen transaktionen
wenn man sich nur den preis ansieht
scheint es bitcoin nicht so hart
getroffen zu haben im moment sehen wir
einen rückgang von 3 prozent er liegt
immer noch bei 43 1351 wie wichtig ist
der chinesische markt für bitcoin
der chinesische markt ist für bitcoin
extrem wichtig die frage ist wird china
es schaffen dass alles durchzusetzen
geht es hier wirklich um ein verbot von
transaktionen oder nicht doch eher um
den besitz von bitcoin denn wenn der
besitz weiterhin legal ist dann muss man
ja auch irgendwie damit handeln können
geht es aber nur um transaktionen dann
ist es eine weitere verschärfung aber
kein verbot dann ist es allerdings auch
kein finanzinstrument mehr denn seien
wir ehrlich bitcoin wird nicht so oft
für transaktionen im finanzsystem
verwendet es wird eher als vermögenswert
gehandelt ähnlich wie eine aktie
hier entsteht gerade eine echte grauzone
ähnlich wie mit marihuana in vielen
staaten der usa man durfte es besitzen
aber man durfte es nicht kaufen oder
verkaufen eingesetzte beschaffung war
nicht klar geregelt sie haben nur gesagt
dass man es besitzen aber weder kaufen
noch verkaufen darf das könnte nun auch
bei bitcoin der fall sein
ich glaube jedem ist klar welche
richtung china hier jetzt einschlägt wir
wissen dass jeder generell nicht gut auf
crypto währungen zu sprechen ist vor
allem nicht bei solchen die sie nicht
kontrollieren können ein digitales asset
der zentralbank wäre hier etwas völlig
anderes ich glaube nicht dass jena dem
ganzen spektrum der krypto währung in
den kampf angesagt hat
die das harte durchgreifen chinas
beschränkt sich leider nicht nur auf
crypto währungen denn wie tommy kennen
sie und sehr bereits berichtete
versuchen sie in allen bereichen gegen
diese risiken vorzugehen das gilt auch
für den immobiliensektor wir wissen
nicht ob eva brand gestern seine
deadline zur zahlungsfrist eingehalten
hat oder nicht was denken sie wird in
den nächsten 24 oder 48 stunden
passieren
wir müssen abwarten und schauen was in
china passiert vielleicht kommt es zu
einer weiteren verschärfung
die chinesische führung hat ein problem
mit dem kapitalismus im allgemeinen und
deshalb ist es für sie schwierig zu
argumentieren wie weit der handel und
die spekulationen auf freien märkten
gehen dürfen
ein ähnlich hartes durchgreifen ist
jedenfalls auch für ausländische firmen
denkbar es ist ja nicht so dass sie die
auswirkungen nicht verhindern könnten
sie wissen genau dass die jeweiligen
anleihegläubiger geld verlieren werden
das steht außer frage
aber können sie auch verhindern dass das
finanzsystem zusammenbricht
dabei ist sich china des potenzials der
block chain technologie durchaus bewusst
und hat sogar eine eigene digitale
währung den digitalen höheren eingeführt
auch hatte das chinesische unternehmen
tencent bereits 2007 ein programm namens
putin ins leben gerufen das im eigenen
messaging dienst youtube eingesetzt
wurde und auch einen eigenen
sekundärmarkt eröffnete infolgedessen
verbot die chinesische regierung 2009
die verwendung digitaler währungen für
den kauf von realen waren und
dienstleistungen bitcoin war eine davon
wurde aber im verbot nicht ausdrücklich
erwähnt die tatsache dass die
chinesische bevölkerung bereits
erfahrung mit digitalen währungen hatte
kam ihm dabei aber zugute
china entwickelte sich somit im laufe
der jahre zum dreh und angelpunkt der
jungen crypto industrie die chinesische
regierung beschloss unterdessen die
entwicklung der digitalen münze
abzuwarten was wiederum den crypto
unternehmen die möglichkeit eröffnete
neue wege zu beschreiten
die erste chinesische bitcoin börse
bietet china wurde 2011 gegründet
gefolgt von den crypto plattformen huby
und bitten im jahr 2013 unternehmen wie
baidu akzeptierten ab sofort bitcoin
zahlungen dies wiederum erregte die
aufmerksamkeit der chinesischen
währungshüter im dezember 2013 gaben sie
bekannt dass chinesische finanzinstitute
keine bitcoin transaktion mehr
durchführen dürften sie erklärten
bitcoin zu einem illegalen
zahlungsmittel
diese ankündigung erfolgte zu einem
zeitpunkt als der bitcoin handel bereits
einen beträchtlichen aufschwung erlebte
und sein kurs knapp zehn tage vor dem
verbot zum ersten mal die 1000 dollar
marke überschritt nach der ankündigung
brach der wert von bitcoin an der damals
größten börse der welt um über 30
prozent ein
für insider campina skripte verbot nicht
völlig überraschend von dem verbot
ausgeschlossen war allerdings das
bitcoin mining dies war weiterhin
erlaubt und günstige rahmenbedingungen
machten china schnell zu einem eldorado
für wird cline mining unternehmen obwohl
die regulierungsbehörde einzelpersonen
nicht vom bitkom handel abhielt riet sie
den beteiligten sich den risiken bewusst
zu sein
wir wissen ja dass china bereits
schritte in diese richtung unternommen
hat aber ein gänzliches verbot ist schon
ziemlich radikal was denken sie was
bedeutet dieser schritt für ein
unternehmen wie falken ex wissen sie
china wollte crypto währungen ja schon
seit einigen jahren für illegal erklären
das haben wir bereits in den jahren 2013
und 2017 gehört es ist auch dieses jahr
schon häufiger angedroht worden das ist
nichts ungewöhnliches für ein
autoritäres regime das versucht seine
eigene digitale währung zu schützen
hinzu kommt das nächste woche der
chinesischen nationalfeiertag ist ihr
hartes durchgreifen gegen crypto und da
bin ich wirklich einer meinung mit
senator to me ist eine große chance für
die vereinigten staaten wir müssen uns
an unseren strukturellen vorteil
gegenüber china erinnern und wie es
bereits erwähnt hat waren die
marktbewegungen historisch gesehen nicht
so dramatisch da haben wir in der
vergangenheit schon schlimmeres gesehen
natürlich sehen wir zurzeit eine
tiefrote kerze nach unten ausgelöste
schnelle panikverkäufe aber
weitestgehend auf asiatischer seite zum
beispiel durch die in asien basierten
hedgefonds wahrscheinlich gefolgt von
einer schnellen markterholung für btc
durch amerikanische institutionen oder
anleger
wer ist der gewinner und der verlierer
können sie konkret in bezug auf die
coins erklären was dies genau bedeutet
das würde uns helfen die situation zu
verstehen
ja das ist wirklich eine sehr gute frage
ich denke historisch gesehen wuchsen wir
in den letzten zwei monaten in hinblick
auf unsere bottom line etwas langsamer
wir sehen heute sieben mal mehr volumen
in der krypto währung und im
traditionellen finanzwesen als in den
wochen davor zwischen
der fokus liegt hier natürlich in erster
linie auf den bekannteren coins wir
haben bereits über theorien gesprochen
aber auch evtl solana aida oder luna
bewegten sich parallel zu bekommen
darüber hinaus auch ein paar tagen die
am rand so bitcoin agieren in erster
linie sehen wir ein wieder erwachtes
interesse an sogenannten playbook die wg
oder ex infinity
wie sie wissen will china ja auch gegen
jeden ermitteln der für crypto währungs
börsen in übersee arbeitet würden
darunter nicht auch alle mitarbeiter
innen von falken ex fallen ich meine was
bedeutet das für folgen ex und die
arbeit in ihrem unternehmen
nun wir haben heute niederlassungen in
den usa und unsere asiatischen
niederlassung befindet sich in indien
somit hat dies also keine direkten
auswirkungen auf unser geschäft aber wie
sie schon sagten ist das auf jeden fall
ein thema für jedes unternehmen dass
mitarbeiter innen und china beschäftigt
da jetzt in asien das früher so etwas
wie das zentrum der krypto innovation
war crypto währung strenger reguliert
wird wird man sich auch hier in den
vereinigten staaten auf härtere
maßnahmen einstellen müssen auch in
europa erwartet man eine verschärfung
der regulierungen wenn wir demnächst
auch hier ein härteres durchgreifen
sehen wo er wird dann in zukunft das
wachstum kommen
ja das ist eine sehr gute frage also
wenn wir nun mal das mining dass li na
ja bereits weitläufig verboten hat als
beispiel nehmen sehen wir dass viele
dieser männer nun in die vereinigten
staaten muss i denn die hash wert liegt
also bei fast 70 prozent des wertes vor
dem verbot wir haben uns also fast
vollständig davon erholt hinzu kommt
dass viele meiner heute in den usa
sitzen und wir sehen wie die community
und die innovation in den vereinigten
staaten wächst und um noch einmal darauf
zurückzukommen
es ist wirklich eine großartige
gelegenheit für die usa zu zeigen dass
wir bei der zusammenarbeit mit dieser
industrie an vorderster front stehen ich
denke dass alle beteiligten versuchen
die verbraucher innen zu schützen ohne
hier innovation zu ersticken das hat für
jedes unternehmen diesem bereich oberste
priorität
2015 machten chinesische bitcoin mining
unternehmen die hälfte der bitcoins raid
aus
die ersten zusätzlichen crypto währungen
durch sogenannte indischen offerings ipo
wurden 2016 geschaffen durchaus können
fiat geld oder andere etablierte
kryptisch gegen trogen einer digitalen
währung getauscht werden im herbst 2017
hatten chinesische eis über 400
millionen dollar eingesammelt und die
chinesische regierung alarmiert in dem
versuch den schwächelnden führen zu
stützen und den illegalen geldabfluss
aus china zu verhindern begann die
zentralbank des landes im januar 2017
die aktivitäten von crypto börsen zu
untersuchen die untersuchung
konzentrierte sich auf die
vorgehensweise der börsen seinem devisen
management und bei der
geldwäschebekämpfung
die people's bank of china hielt als sie
aus für einen illegalen mechanismus zur
mittelbeschaffung
sie verbot den plattformen die ausgabe
von toben und ordnete an dass die über
alle eingenommenen gelder an die
investoren zurückgegeben werden müssten
die aufsichtsbehörde stellte unter
anderem fest dass sie es die stabilität
der wirtschaft des landes bedrohen und
das risiko eines geschäfts ausfalls
bergen die anordnung legte auch fest
dass finanzinstitute und nicht bank
zahlungs unternehmen keine
dienstleistungen anbieten dürften die
token basierte fundraising aktivitäten
unterstützen
während jena skripte gemeinschaft noch
dabei war diese neue realität zu
verarbeiten er ließen die
regulierungsbehörden eine weitere
anweisung nur zwei wochen später wurden
crypto börsen auf denen der umtausch von
vier zu crypto geld möglich war
endgültig verboten infolgedessen
verlagerten zahlreiche bitcoin
plattformen ihre aktivitäten ins ausland
während andere gezwungen waren ihre
plattformen ganz zu schließen was haben
sie gedacht als sie von chinas vorstoß
werden
ich denke wir haben die
widerstandsfähigkeit der krippe märkte
gegenüber einer sich annähernd in
regulierung und insbesondere einer sich
ändernden regulierung in china schon
mehrmals gesehen es ist schwer
vorherzusagen wie sich eine verschärfung
auf die gatekeeper oder die
verschiedenen akteure auf dem markt
auswirkt aber es ist klar dass es
unmöglich ist bitcoin selbst zu
regulieren da die nutzung des
dezentralen protokolls und bitcoin oder
andere klub tus nicht reguliert werden
kann
ich denke es gibt eine menge
diskussionen darüber dass es im
september 2017 auch eine art große tina
verbot für crypto währungen und börsen
karten danach sahen wir so etwas wie die
erste große kulturelle des jahres 20 17
worauf bitkom ein neues rekordhoch
erreichte
regulierungen von bitcoin funktionieren
ähnlich wie bei einer hydra schlägt man
einen kopf ab bekommt man dafür fünf
weitere köpfe
wird könnt gerade als ein mehrköpfiges
monster beschrieben okay das lassen wir
einfach mal so stehen aber um auf ihren
punkt zurück zu kommen es ist ja das
argument vieler bitcoin enthusiasten
dass eine menge leute mit bitkom handeln
und ist viele unterschiedliche wege
geben wird mit bitcoin handeln zu können
doch wenn china wirklich beschließt man
darf bitcoin nicht besetzen nicht
benutzen und auch nichthandeln ich meine
inwiefern kann das keine ernsten
auswirkungen auf den preis und das
volumen von kripo haben die
globale weltwirtschaft ist halt viel
größer als ein einzelner staat wir sehen
übrigens auch einen wandel von hyper
lokalen kapitalmärkten auf denen nur
lokal gehandelt wird hin zu globalen
kapitalmärkten und crypto märkte sind
natürlich super global und somit das
gegenteil von lokalen kapitalmärkten
es wird definitiv immer auswirkungen
verschiedener regulierungen auf den
crypto markt geben aber ich denke wir
werden wieder die widerstandsfähigkeit
eines globalen die zentralisierten
geldsystems sehen und wir werden in
diesem jahr eine aufregende verschiebung
mehr in richtung die feier also zu
verschiedenen dezentralisierten
protokollen und finanzsystemen sehen die
branche wird sich stärker in richtung
defy gelegen
ist das risiko viel größer und ich denke
wir sind uns einig dass andere crypto
währungen eine größere bedrohung für die
zentralbanken darstellen als bitcoin der
wohl mehr oder weniger eine klasse für
sich ist zentralbanken insbesondere die
federal reserve und sicherlich auch die
ezb werden sich hier ebenso einmischen
und dann entscheiden können wie wann und
in welcher form crypto gehandelt werden
soll auch könnten die zentralbanken ihre
eigene digitale währung auf fiat basis
durchsetzen wie groß ist dieses risiko
dass wir so was wie in china hier bei
uns sehen könnten
sie wissen ich bin optimist jedes risiko
ist auch eine chance es besteht kein
zweifel dass die digitalisierung des
geldes begonnen hat und wir bereits die
weitgehende digitale transformation des
geldes sehen können die block chain
technologie und der bitcoin stehen für
eine neue art von globalisierung
regierungen und behörden werden
natürlich nach möglichkeiten suchen sie
zu regulieren wir werden viele
zentralbanken und regierungen sehen die
versuchen werden ihre eigenen digitalen
währungen einzuführen
ich denke das wird parallel zu den
bisherigen crypto märkten laufen eine
andere art von vermögenswert dieser
gesamte prozess die verlagerung des
gesamten geldsystems in den digitalen
bereich ist eine art wettrüsten zwischen
vielen verschiedenen ländern auf der
ganzen welt
juni eine letzte kurze frage gab es seit
chinas ankündigung veränderungen im
handel auf ihrer plattform
nun wir sehen ein generelles
handelsmuster dass sich in der
volatilität widerspiegelt wenn die
volatilität hoch ist sehen wir mehr
handelsaktivität und der preis steigt
im mai sahen wir eine preiskorrektur von
bitcoin achtem einem verbot anfang
august an das erwachen vieler die
protokolle das bitcoin und auch täter
ebenfalls deutlich wiederbelebt hat
ich glaube dass die märkte nach dieser
korrektur etwas ausgeglichener sind als
noch vor einem monat
als folge dieser entwicklung verlagerte
einige in china ansässiger börsen ihren
betrieb in andere länder während auch
viele ihre geschäfte einstellen mussten
im april 2009 10 bezeichnete chinas
nationale entwicklungs und
reformkommission ndrc das bitcoin mining
als unerwünschte industrie in ihrer
vorläufigen liste von sektoren die von
lokalen regierungen gefördert
eingeschränkt oder abgeschafft werden
sollten bitcoin mining ein computer
intensiver prozess zur validierung von
bitcoin transaktionen fiel in den
katalog die die behörde als besonders
umweltschädlich einstufte wie zu
erwarten war löste diese entwicklung
eine gewisse panik aus da ein
erheblicher prozentsatz der bitcoin
mining rix in china hergestellt wurde
außerdem war mehr als die hälfte der
weltweiten bitcoin mining leistung in
china angesiedelt da die betreiber dort
zugang zu billigem strom hatten obwohl
die andy auch das bitcoin mining nach
reiflicher überlegung schließlich aus
ihrem endgültigen entwurf strich war die
ganze episode ein erster vorgeschmack
auf das was noch kommen sollte
brechen wir über die neuesten meldungen
aus china inwiefern unterscheiden sich
diese von früheren meldungen und warum
glauben sie hat der markt sie so schnell
abgeschmettert
so geht die berg wie ja genauso gut mord
nie war schön wieder hier zu sein das
jüngste verbot ist nur eine weitere
verschärfung der krippe politik in china
seit sommer gibt es gerüchte dass jeder
irgendwann vom crypto börsenmarkt
abgeschnitten sein wird wie sie
vielleicht wissen haben bio sie und die
regulierungsbehörden bereits vor vier
jahren einheimische börsen in china
verboten darauf wurden viele der börsen
einfach ins ausland verlegt
wir erreichen unsere kunden auf dem
chinesischen festland immer noch da sie
einen vpn zugang nutzen können wenn sie
also von transaktionen entsprechend ist
dieses verbot meiner meinung nach ein
kleiner interpretations fehler es geht
wirklich um krupp die käufe und verkäufe
die krypto tausch transaktionen die auf
börsen plattformen stattfinden ich
glaube dass private börsen die von
privaten verkäufern betrieben werden
weiterhin erlaubt sind es dreht sich nur
um die durch unternehmen geführt dieses
vorgehen wird jetzt als illegal
angesehen und strafrechtlich verfolgt
aus diesem grund haben die großen börsen
plattformen in china in den letzten zwei
tagen angekündigt die registrierung
chinesischer nutzer zu stoppen
bobby was glauben sie ist der grund für
das festhalten
chinas an diesen harten kurs gegen
crypto währungen ist es immer noch die
sorge um das risiko der geldwäsche durch
crypto währung oder geht es jetzt eher
um energieverbrauch oder die gefahr
einer digitalen bedrohung für den
renminbi was glauben sie tracking an
ich denke es hat eine menge mit
kontrollierbarer währung zu tun sie
wissen schon in einem system in dem
alles kontrolliert wird wie die wiesn et
cetera will man natürlich fremdwährungen
kontrollieren sie möchten schlupflöcher
oder instrumente verhindern die es
möglich machen vermögenswerte ins
ausland zu verschieben das ist der grund
um kontrolle über die wirtschaft und
finanzen bzw den geldabfluss zu behalten
letzten endes geht es beim einem verbot
nicht um die energie ich glaube sie
versuchen mich eher eine angleichung
aller crypto währungen zu erreichen
durch das mining verbot aber wie bereits
gesagt halte ich das nicht für der
todesstoß der das sogenannte illegale
halten von crypto vermögenswerten sein
soll das ist eindeutig nicht der fall
so dass nachher
berichten uns schon seit wochen und
monaten über die köpfe meiner und china
viele weichen nun ins ausland aus bobby
sie sind ja vor ort in shanghai können
sie einschätzen wie sich die aktivität
tatsächlich bisher verlagert hat
ein großer teil des traditionellen
mannings von crypto währungen das
sogenannte bruder ist ins ausland
verlagert worden die lear es zb bei
bitcoin leid kriterium sehen es gibt
eine neue kategorie von meinem bei der
es um 5 auf steak geht also um die
lagerung wie bei vossel coin und anderen
es diese werden weiterhin in china
betrieben weil es viel schwieriger ist
sie zu lokalisieren
es handelt sich dabei um ganz normale
computer die mit solid state drives
ausgerüstet sind es ist sehr schwer
diesen relativ normalen energiebedarf
als leistungsnachweis fürs mining zu
klassifizieren
[Musik]
ok bobby vielleicht sagen sie uns noch
wie momentan die aussichten sind was ist
ihre prognose sie sprachen davon dass
frühere maßnahmen aus peking zu einem
erneuten boom des bitkom kreises geführt
habe glauben sie dass es dieses mal
ähnlich sein wird
es ist so eine sache mit diesen
gerüchten oft werden diese als
nachrichten verkauft also sell on good
news und so etwas passiert ja auch
gerade freundlich hier das gerücht dass
jene an diesem jahr sehr hart gegen
bitcoin vorgehen wird hält sich schon
seit einigen monaten nun ist der hammer
endlich gefallen es erinnert mich an
2017 als im september hart
durchgegriffen wurde und darauf die
bitkom preise gegen ende 20 17 auf ein
mehrjahreshoch gestiegen sind
dieses jahr wird es wohl nicht anders
laufen wenn die schlechten nachrichten
aus dem weg geräumt sind denke ich
reagierte crypto markt sehr bullish vor
allem für die wiederkehrende
jahresendrallye erwarte ich dass die
bitkom preise in den nächsten wochen und
monaten wieder ausbrechen
nun gut wir bewegen uns immer noch um
die 43.000 marke und sind über das
wochenende sogar unter diese marke
gefallen
okay aber ich frage mich nur warum
63.000 es immer noch weit weg was
glauben sie wie sich die preise
tatsächlich entwickeln werden wenn wir
von der bevorstehenden jahresend-rally
sprechen
ich denke dass preise über 100.000
dollar durchaus möglich sind und je
nachdem wie stark die rallye verläuft
wand sogar die 200er marke oder höher
erreicht
natürlich wären 200.000 dollar ein
echter meilenstein
es wird wieder eine menge berichte hier
zu geben und das führt wahrscheinlich zu
einer weiteren for more rallye also
einer angst etwas zu verpassen rallye so
etwas passiert im allgemeinen alle paar
jahre und ich denke dass eine erneute
rallye für bitcoin schon lange fällig
ist
wir sind gleich am ende unseres beitrags
bobby wir haben ein hartes durchgreifen
der regulierungsbehörden in china
gesehen von finn tag bis hin zu crypto
hat das in irgendeiner weise einfluss
auf ihre geschäftsbeziehungen und ihre
arbeit mit beller
ja das stimmt wir haben uns auf den
verkauf von hardware wollitz
spezialisiert daher sind wir von den
regulierungen nicht betroffen und das
bereits mein zweites startup ist wollte
ich mich von anfang an nicht nur auf den
chinesischen markt verlassen natürlich
sind unsere verkäufe mit den frühen
sanktionen in china auch zurückgegangen
dies stellt für uns aber kein großes
problem dar weil wir uns frühzeitig auf
dem internationalen markt für crypto
währungen positioniert haben somit
machen die jüngsten sanktionen für
unternehmen die ihre aktivitäten nicht
nur auf china konzentrieren keinen
unterschied allerdings trifft das
unternehmen die sich auf den
chinesischen markt konzentrieren um so
mehr
nach der erklärung des staatsrats
begannen die provinzregierungen
proaktive maßnahmen zu ergreifen um das
crypto mining zu unterbinden die
regulierungsbehörden begründeten das
neue vorgehen vor allem damit das
bitcoin sehr energieintensiv sei und
eine gefahr für die umwelt ziele des
landes darstelle
dass die krippe und das tri intensiv an
einer umweltfreundlicheren variante des
bitcoins fonds wurde bereits mit dem cia
green jobs projekt vorgestellt sie wurde
als der grüne alt kontrolliert warum ist
der grüne als bitcoin
zunächst einmal anstatt auf eine menge
strom und benutzerdefinierte hardware zu
vertrauen um sicher zu gehen dass die
blog seien korrekt funktioniert setzen
wir stattdessen auf ungenutzten
festplattenspeicher china nutzt eine
kombination aus proof of space und proof
of life style auch konsens algorithmus
genannt beim konsens algorithmus zuvor
verletzt heim wird für jeden knoten
innerhalb eines netzwerkes eine
zufällige zeitspanne gewählt diese
zeitspanne musste nutzer schlicht
abwarten welcher nutzer nun den neuen
block generiert entscheide die länge der
wartezeit die kürzeste wartezeit
generierte neuen blog darf ihn in der
blogs hinzuweisen und erhält die
belohnung in konz
beim proof of space wird nicht
verwendeter festplattenspeicher als
speicherplatz verwendet um diesen
nachzuweisen müssen nutzer eine software
installieren die eine sammlung
kryptographischer nummern auf der
festplatte speichert festplatten
verbrauchen so deutlich weniger strom
wenn man alle festplatten die in diesem
jahr ausgeliefert wurden was ungefähr
ein zettabyte darstellt wie die tier i
um vergleicht so ist das etwa ein
zehntel des gesamten energieverbrauchs
pro jahr wenn hier also die nachfrage
steigt schafft dass da nicht automatisch
auch einen mehrbedarf an speicher und
festplatten was ja letztendlich wieder
mehrbelastung und ein weiteres problem
für die umwelt darstellt nun es gibt
zwei dinge die hier wichtig sind zu
betrachten das eine ist sie wissen genau
dass ein fahrrad viel effizienter ist
als ein tesla aber das heißt nicht dass
wir nicht wollen dass tesla mit suvs
konkurriert wir sind eine sehr viel
grünere alternative und bieten außerdem
mehr sicherheit als mit können und dass
theorie und wir haben etwa 500.000 trotz
im vergleich zu bitcoins 40.000 aber was
wir eigentlich tun ist das für
gebrauchte festplatten wieder in den
markt zurück holen bei cryptic pharma
sie von facebook oder box nach ihrer
vierjährigen einsatzdauer abkaufen und
diese festplatten nutzen anstatt sie auf
dem müll zu werfen
sie haben neulich erst ihren börsengang
verkündet und so wie ich es verstehe es
der plan eine eigene handelsplattform
ein breites zahlungssystem zu entwickeln
können sie uns sagen wie ihre ambition
insgesamt aussehen ja wir glauben dass
die blog schon im jahr 2017 längst diese
marktfähigkeit hätte erlangen sollen
aber es gab regulatorische probleme und
auch die funktionalität der block schön
war wirklich noch nicht reif für den
übergang auf unternehmen oder behörden
unsere neu entwickelte innovative blog
shame programmiersprache namens schall
ist heute sehr viel weiter entwickelt um
dinge wie digitale währungen digitale
börsen kreditmärkte oder auch aktien zu
stützen eine sache die wir wirklich
anders gemacht haben ist die
unternehmensform zu wählen die uns eine
einführung einer blog chain erlaubt wir
erwarten eine art redhat geschäft
aufzubauen indem wir unternehmen bei der
einführung der block stand infrastruktur
unterstützen die idee an die börse zu
gehen ist eine reine produktstrategie
für viele unternehmen ist es eine art
exit strategie ein ausweg für uns stellt
es ein weg da die regularien zu klären
es macht es uns einfacher zu erklären
dies ist unser kapital im gegensatz zu
unseren coins sie eine reine ware
darstellen und es erlaubt unseren
nutzern zum beispiel unser eigenkapital
zu verwenden um sich von der volatilität
abzuschirmen die diese coins oft haben
nun offenbar steckt grundsätzlich eine
menge volatilität im kriftel markt aber
inzwischen sieht es so aus als wäre sie
ja selbst sehr volatil was halten sie
davon
ich denke hier versucht gerade seinen
marktpreis zu finden und wissen sie ich
denke es pendelt sich so langsam ein
wenn man sich die letzten zwei wochen so
ansieht lag es in der spanne von 600 bis
700 dollar am crypto markt ist das
tatsächlich eine ziemlich enge spanne
die hier nicht gerade üblich sind sie
sagen es ist grüner als bitcoin ist es
auch grüner als
also die sache mit dem hören ist dass es
bereits die letzten zwei jahre hieß in
drei monaten kommt die 2.0 version
wir glauben nicht dass der proof of
state wirklich sicher ist wenn es um
eine zwischenstaatliche art von
wettbewerb geht der proof of state weist
noch eine menge probleme auf die nach
nakamoto konsens das bitcoin übrigens
ist und wir bereits auch noch weit
entfernt von wirklich gelöst sind wie
sie wissen gibt es beim fußweg immer
noch das problem dass 51% angriffs der
wenn er erfolgreich ist die gesamte
block shane und ihre transaktionen
manipuliert
aber die antwort auf die frage der
ökologischen nachhaltigkeit ist nicht
allein schlüssel zum erfolg china gibt
zwar immer wieder ökologische gründe an
um weitere regulierungen durchzusetzen
aber die antwort auf die frage der
ökologischen nachhaltigkeit wurde bisher
nicht beantwortet
ist die antwort auf die frage der
ökologischen nachhaltigkeit von crypto
wirklich der schlüssel zum erfolg
guten morgen danke dass ich hier sein
darf ich denke das ist eine wirklich
wichtige frage für eine branchen und
unternehmen und crypto stellt keine
ausnahme dar es trifft nicht allein und
ich denke das wirklich interessante an
der krippe wirtschaft ist dass sie eine
art maximale maschen effizienz mitbringt
erst sucht sich immer die günstigsten
energiequellen und wir wissen ja dass
dies erneuerbare energien sind die
neuesten statistiken zeigen dass crypto
mining insbesondere das bitcoin mining
am kostenintensivsten ist ungefähr 50
bis 60 prozent hiervon wird durch
erneuerbare energien gedeckt was weit
über dem industriedurchschnitt liegt
es ist also noch ein langer weg für die
krypto industrie und ein sehr wichtiger
teil ihrer geschichte die neuen verbote
aus china die sie erwähnt haben sind nur
eine von vielen die noch kommen werden
es wird also eine größere
herausforderung für china angenommen und
das ist etwas über das wir natürlich
nicht so glücklich sind dass mining
verbot in china anfang des jahres hat
dazu geführt dass sich meiner ins
ausland verlagert haben
das mining in china macht nur noch 55
des weltweiten anteils aus und der wird
wahrscheinlich weiter zurückgehen und je
mehr sich das meininger aus china ins
ausland und an andere orte verlagert an
denen erneuerbare energien schneller und
besser genutzt werden zb den usa desto
mehr wird sich der energiemix für
kriftel währungen länder
die verschiedenen blog chains wie zum
beispiel bitcoin oder auch terium werden
sicherlich nach alternativen wegen
suchen um ihre netzwerke zu sichern der
prüfungstag ist eine alternative methode
zur sicherung dieser transaktionen und
zur sicherung des distributed ledger
viele neue technologien neue coins und
bereits bestehende coins stellen auf
diese art von methodik um und ich denke
das wird auswirkungen haben
die nachhaltigkeit des proof of state
wäre auch direkt meine nächste frage
gewesen denn selbst bei den proof of
state basierenden blog chains sind die
unterschiede untereinander groß richtig
ich meine in der theorie rangiert man
hier ziemlich weit unten
nachhaltigkeit ist definitiv ein teil
davon ich denke unsere generation muss
sogar auf erneuerbare energien umsteigen
damit crypto währung sich schneller
entwickeln kann erneuerbare energien
sind nun mal die energiequellen der
zukunft tatsächlich gibt es einige sehr
interessante australische projekte wie
zum beispiel modulare mining projekte
jedes neue projekt muss teil der
energiewende seien oder können diese
zumindest unterstützen
das meinen für grippe währungen kann
durchaus vor ort realisiert werden ich
kenne projekte die sich lokal ansiedeln
und mit einem überangebot zu kämpfen
haben
in australien gibt es ein überangebot
wenn es um die spitzenlast der
solarenergie geht hier kann man diesen
modularen ansatz und verbrauch nutzen
bitcoin ist nicht der feind er ist teil
des übergangs und ein interessantes
werkzeug in diesem prozess das
eigentliche problem sind wir und unsere
umsetzung wenn wir etwas ändern wird
sich auch die gruppe industrie ändern
wir haben neue experimente mit
grenzüberschreitenden digitalen
währungen durch die banken gesehen ganz
zu schweigen von der währungsbehörde
chinas und hongkongs welchen einfluss
werden diese digitalen währungen oder
cbs auf andere crypto währungen haben
das ist eine wirklich interessante frage
denn wir haben vor kurzem gesehen dass
plattformen wie twitter konto währungen
in ihr netzwerk aufgenommen haben man
kann also leute für seine plattform
begeistern indem man bitcoin verwendet
und es gab einige wirklich interessante
videos die zeigen die leute
grenzüberschreitend trinkgeld gegen
plötzlich ist twitter also nicht nur ein
soziales netzwerk sondern eine plattform
für grenzüberschreitende zahlungen und
genau das ist die stärke von block chain
und drückt im internet verankert können
sie in jeder app integriert werden
interessant ist auch der einzug
digitaler währungen von zentralbanken in
den letzten 12 bis 24 monaten wurde
durch stable konz und die verwendung von
crypto währungen im
grenzüberschreitenden verkehr bewiesen
dass es sich um eine überlegene form von
geld handelt die zentralbanken werden
sich diese technologie zu nutze machen
wissen sie es ist eine art internet 3.0
in einem land wie china werden diese
dinge leider weiterhin nebeneinander
existieren müssen sie versuchen ihre
eigene art von digitaler währung
durchzusetzen aber die akzeptanz zur
technologie und im allgemeinen ist
vorhanden
das ist sicherlich bedauerlich für
aufstrebende chinesische unternehmen und
die chinesische gemeinschaft die schnell
auf diese neue art von technologie setzt
crypto währungen und digitale währungen
der zentralbanken werden in zukunft
nebeneinander bestehen müssen
wenn es um die einführung neuer
technologien die entwicklung ihrer
digitalen währung und vielleicht auch um
regulierung geht was denken sie welche
länder sind hier führend
neben den amerikanern sind wir in
australien natürlich eine stolze crypto
nation und haben eine gewisse präsenz
hier vor ort verschiedene länder haben
verschiedene herangehensweisen der
regulatorische rahmen kann sich
natürlich jederzeit ändern und das trägt
natürlich eine menge tanz bei wenn sie
mich jetzt fragen wer die
fortschrittlichsten crypto länder sind
können wir natürlich nicht die länder
unerwähnt lassen die krypto bereits als
gesetzliches zahlungsmittel eingeführt
haben wie zb el salvador aber es gibt
eben so viel innovation in europa aus
der spaltung viele stiftung ihren sitz
haben hier gibt es interessante
technologien
auch in den usa gibt es eine menge an
dynamischen und spannenden projekten es
handelt sich um eine globale technologie
es kommt darauf an ob die menschen die
dort sind diese technologie annehmen und
in australien gibt es wirklich
faszinierende projekte
für den großteil des jahres 2020
verschärfte die chinesische regierung
ihren blick auf crypto börsenaktivitäten
im rahmen einer laufenden kampagne zur
bekämpfung von geldwäsche und betrug im
august gab die pb sie ihre absicht
bekannt über 100 ausländische websites
zu sperren die krypto börsen anbieten
die probleme der chinesischen crypto
industrie im jahr 2021 begannen im mai
als der staatsrat die einschränkung von
crypto mining und handel forderte zuvor
hatten die behörden der provinz innere
mongolei xinjiang und sieht die allesamt
wichtige bitcoin mining die scheiben
waren damit begonnen den betrieb von
bitcoin meinen einzuschränken
ähnlich wie bei der verfolgung von
crypto börsen im jahr 2017 waren die
bitcoin meiner gezwungen entweder ihre
tätigkeit dauerhaft einzustellen oder in
andere crypto freundlichere länder
umzuziehen da rund 50 prozent der
weltweiten bitcoin mining leistung vor
dem verbot in china erzeugt wurde bekam
die globale bitcoin wirtschaft
erwartungsgemäß die auswirkungen des
verbots zu spüren
was halten sie davon dass ich peking
immer mehr von crypto währungen abwendet
guten morgen und vielen dank für die
einladung nun selbst wenn man von der
ganzen crypto problematik mal absieht
denke ich dass dies womöglich auch eine
fehlgeleitete soft power aktion chinas
sein könnte um anderen ländern zu zeigen
dass man in china kein einflussbereich
durch crypto gewinnen kann wenn man sich
länder wie el salvadors oder afghanistan
anschaut dann sind das alles länder die
sich auf crypto währung zu bewegen
während china sich zurückzieht
wie sie wissen haben die chinesen
weltweit viel mühe und ressourcen
investiert um ihre einflussnahme zu
stärken vor allem in lateinamerika und
in den ländern und regionen in denen ihr
einfluss schwindet wird es in zukunft
probleme geben
ja wir haben sogar gesehen wie ftx ihren
hauptsitz von hongkong auf die bahamas
verlegt haben diese verlagerung nach
lateinamerika die sie erwähnten was
bedeutet das in der praxis für
unternehmen die beziehungen zu china
haben und insbesondere für die
chinesischen nutzer
ja das ist durchaus richtig wenn man
sich mal die beiden größten
handelsplätze hobby oder ok ex anschaut
okay es ist ja ein gigant des
chinesischen crypto handels bei beiden
sahen wie am wochenende deutlich die
auswirkungen
es gab erhebliche werte verluste ihrer
toten im handel
und sicherlich werden unternehmen die in
china selbst agieren oder chinesische
kunden haben über das wochenende und
darüber hinaus mühe haben sich zu
positionieren
für jeden akteure hier involviert ist
werden die kommenden tage wichtig sein
aber ich denke auch es ist gut die
krippe industrie als eine eigene branche
zu sehen die ihre robustheit schon
mehrfach unter beweis gestellt hat dies
ist bereits das zweite mal in diesem
jahr dass china versucht crypto
währungen zu verbieten
ja durch das jüngste verbot verzeichnete
die branche im juni ein einbruch des
bitkom preises aber wir sehen natürlich
auch was in den monaten danach passierte
und das ist ein weiterer beweis für die
robustheit von krypton insbesondere wenn
man sich den globalen markt anschaut wir
werden also mit großem interesse
verfolgen was in china passiert aber
auch die regulierungen in anderen
ländern beobachten wir genau
insbesondere wie die verlagerung des
bitcoin links in richtung westen
verlaufen wird wie wir sie im laufe
dieses jahres bereits beobachten konnten
also ja absolut unternehmen die einen
direkten handel mit crypto und china
tätigen müssen sich sorgen und nun
schauen was die zukunft bringt
allerdings sehe ich keine großen
verluste für den rest der branche die
erschütterungen gewohnt und global gut
aufgestellt ist
allein wenn wir uns langfristig den
trend rabbit köln anschauen wir sind ja
immer noch ziemlich weit vom allzeithoch
über 60.000 entfernt sehen sie hier eine
schnelle markterholung und wie viel
davon hat tatsächlich mit nachrichten
aus china zu tun ich meine man hat das
gefühl dass es seit 2009 10 für crypto
immer schwieriger wird sich zu
stabilisieren
ja absolut ich denke dass der
preisrückgang den wir gesehen haben auch
ein indiz dafür ist zehn prozent der
krypto sind über das wochenende um 5 bis
7 prozent gefallen
hinzu kommt noch social media zum
beispiel heißt es auf twitter nutzer
innen könnten nun bitcoin für ihre
aktivitäten nutzen gleichzeitig
erreichen uns negative nachrichten aus
china denen circa 330 millionen twitter
user gegenüber stehen die jetzt in der
lage sein werden bitcoin für social
media transaktionen zu verwenden
es spricht vieles für einen erneuten
aufschwung ob ich glaube dass wir wieder
einen preis von 60.000 dollar sehen
werden es deutet alles darauf hin dass
wir uns in diese richtung bewegen werden
ich glaube ich dass wir langfristig mehr
anwendungen für wird können sehen werden
auf jeden fall
allerdings wäre es ziemlich naiv zu
sagen das bitcoin die einzige option
darstellt ich denke die geschichte hat
den menschen immer wieder gezeigt wie
schnell sich tauschmittel oder
wertanlagen ändern können ich kann mir
sehr gut vorstellen dass es neben
bitcoin eine menge anderer anwärter auf
den crypto thron geben wird
wenn wir nun mal auf australien schauen
da gibt es derzeit vier bedenken
gegenüber der krypto industrie zb bei
themen wie nachhaltigkeit oder
regulierungen liegt australien im
vergleich zu singapur oder dem namen
osten weit zurück erwarten sie dass es
hier einen innovationsschub für crypto
währungen geben wird oder besteht sogar
die chance dass eines dieser länder
chinas führung übernimmt
in der tat ist das eine große chance für
australien und das ist sicherlich auch
die botschaft du die branche versucht
der regierung und den
regulierungsbehörden zu vermitteln wir
sind gespannt auf den bericht den der
senat noch in diesem monat entschuldigen
sie bitte im oktober nächsten jahres
vorlegen wird
die chance ist sehr real da sich china
wohl aus diesem bereich zurückziehen
will für länder wie australien bietet
sich jetzt die gelegenheit wirklich
voranzukommen denn wir haben die
möglichkeit nachhaltiges bitcoin mining
mit all den green energy solutions die
uns zur verfügung stehen zu betreiben
wenn man sich zb den iran anschaut der
diese chance ergriffen hat und
inzwischen 4,5 des weltweiten bitcoin
nichts beisteuert dann zeigt uns dass
welche möglichkeiten ein solcher schritt
bietet wir müssen uns hier fragen ob wir
diese gelegenheit dem iran oder server
darüber lassen wollen oder ob australien
dass so viele möglichkeiten bietet in
diesem bereich auch vorangehen sollte
schauen wir uns nur die entwicklung
singapurs an ein echter leuchtturm in
der krypto branche
ich denke hier gibt es für australien
die möglichkeit für eine enge
partnerschaft und zusammenarbeit in
dieser industrie um hier einen
effizienten und nachhaltigen weg zu
finden
australien ist in der lage die krypto
industrie sehr stark voran zu treiben
wenn china nun auch noch versucht einen
teil des skriptes zu unterbinden wie
genau werden die preise darauf reagieren
es war eine unglaublich volatile woche
für den bitcoin die jüngsten nachrichten
aus china haben ihn wieder einmal hart
getroffen es ist das zweite mal in
dieser woche dass sich nachrichten aus
china direkt auf crypto währungen
ausgewirkt haben zuerst mit der aussage
dass es dem finanzsektor nicht mehr
erlaubt ist crypto zu benutzen und dass
sie noch härter dagegen vorgehen werden
und jetzt die nachricht über das harte
durchgreifen bei mining das hat die
kripo und das dreh noch einmal richtig
getroffen
ja ich meine das stellt viele leute da
draußen auf die probe es ist gut dass
crypto nicht an wochenenden ausbrechen
kann richtig
eine fangfrage
bitte
crypto währung könnte am wochenende
durchaus eine verschnaufpause gebraucht
aber sie wird weiter gehandelt und
dieses wochenende könnten wir sogar noch
mehr bewegungen sehen da die volumina an
wochenenden normalerweise geringer sind
das bedeutet vielleicht sogar noch ein
anstieg der volatilität
claire wir finden es toll dass auch am
wochenende gehandelt wird das bedeutet
sie können auch am samstag und sonntag
ihrem geliebten job als reporterin
nachgehen
lassen sie uns über die zukünftige
entwicklung nachdenken wenn solche
kommentare aus china öfter kommen macht
dass die währungen oder den crypto raum
nicht sehr volatil was bedeutet das für
die zukunft
nun das einzige was sicher erscheint ist
wohl die volatilität von bitcoin aus
gesprächen mit anleger innen habe ich
entnommen dass diese bewegungen den
breiteren crypto mag zwar auf eine art
und weise beeinflussen es offensichtlich
aber nicht der hauptfaktor ist ich denke
investorinnen die mit aktien und
anleihen handeln blicken zurückhaltend
auf bitcoin und mögen es nicht irgendwie
beeinflusst zu werden so kann man schon
eine gewisse risikoscheu beobachten
gerade ein bitcoin erneut unter druck
gerät und das könnte sich fortsetzen
ich meine wir haben gesehen dass diese
korrelationen vor allem in dieser woche
und letzter woche wirklich eine art
parallel bewegung in bezug auf crypto
und einigen anderen risiko-assets
hervorgerufen haben für viele ist crypto
eine art absicherung gegen die normale
volatilität des aktienmarktes werden
diese korrelation hier fortbesteht wird
das vielleicht zu einem weiteren
ausbruch führen hat schon jemand daran
gedacht
ja ein wenig denke ich die leute
konzentrieren sich hauptsächlich auf die
inflation und achten sehr auf eventuelle
anzeichen es stellt sich ja auch die
frage wie der bitkom reagiert wenn die
inflation weiterhin steigt wir wissen
natürlich dass die tech-branche
steigende inflationswerte nicht mag aber
ich denke die idee von bitcoin als
absicherung entwickelt sich noch weiter
und leute versuchen herauszufinden was
mit den preisbewegungen am häufigsten
korreliert
[Musik]
als ob das verbot des bitkom 1 nicht
schon genug wäre beschlossen die
chinesischen regulierungsbehörden im
september den crypto handel ganz zu
verbieten
die zentralbank des landes räumte
daraufhin in zusammenarbeit mit der
polizei und des obersten gerichtshofs
alle zweifel an der haltung des landes
zu crypto währung aus und ließ keinen
raum für fehlinterpretationen
[Musik]
die regulierungsbehörden stuften alle
crypto transaktionen sowohl vier zu
crypto als auch crypto zur crypto den
handel und investitionen als illegal ein
unabhängig davon ob sie über lokale oder
ausländische plattformen abgewickelt
wurden dies schloss alle bitcoin ist
helium und tessa transaktionen ein
chinesische staatsangehörige die im
marketing oder im technischen support
für ausländische börsen arbeiteten
konnten nun strafrechtlich verfolgt
werden die andy ausgelegte pläne zum
vollständigen ausstieg aus dem crypto
mein ding vor indem sie investitionen in
den sektor einstellte die stromkosten
erhöhte und neun unternehmen den zugang
zur branche verwehrte wie kennt ihr
schon sagte wir haben diese geschichte
schon einmal erlebt das ist keine allzu
große überraschung bedeutet das einen
großen rückschlag für die cryptic
gemeinschaft sie haben vollkommen recht
und vielen dank dass ich hier sein darf
dies ist nicht das erste mal dass
chinesische regulierungsbehörden eine
solche erklärung abgegeben habe frühere
versuche crypto währungen zu verbieten
verliefen ja weitestgehend in sande
außerdem ist es bemerkenswert dass es
kurz nach der flucht vieler meiner in
die mongolei angekündigt wurde es ist
also etwas mehr dynamik ins spiel was
preisentwicklung und fundamentaldaten
angeht
also ist erfahren ich bin neugierig sie
haben die heutige kursentwicklung
beobachtet bitcoin ist um fast neun
prozent gefallen natürlich gibt es kunst
die deutlich stärker gefallen sind wie
zb isa der glaube ich um ungefähr elf
prozent gefallen ist bitcoin war heute
morgen trotzdem so etwas wie ein
outperformer wirkte vielleicht für
anleger innen wie eine art zuflucht
es ist sehr klar das bitcoin für viele
eine art zufluchtsort darstellt ich
denke auch dass es sich vielmehr um die
fundamentale frage dreht ist bitcoin ein
verlässliches vermögenswert wenn man
sieht dass er eine art fundamentale
unterstützung findet hier ist das
verständlich die leute haben ihre
fundamentalen metriken diese übertragen
sie auf bitcoin hier halten wir also
allen niveau das wir bei einigen neueren
konz nicht sehen diese basieren auf sie
wissen hochspekulativen anwendungsfällen
etc ich denke diese abverkäufe gerade
ergeben einen sinn für biete sie denke
ich gibt es noch eine menge grundlegende
argumente und der wird seine
unterstützung bald finden
lea wenn wir uns wieder der
kursentwicklung zu wenden auch wenn es
hier keine echten neuigkeiten zu
betreuen und anderen crypto währungen
gab nähern wir uns dennoch dem
wochenende und wir wissen ja dass der
krypto markt an den wochenenden weit
geöffnet ist und so großer volatilität
neigt was erwarten sie wo wir am
montagmorgen stehen
ja absolut
die assets scheinen ihren bodensatz
gefunden zu haben aber wie sie schon
sagten neigen die wochenenden dazu sehr
volatil zu sein und wie sich das
entwickeln wird kann man jetzt nur raten
bitcoin ist um etwa 10% gefallen hat bei
etwa 40.000 seinen widerstand gefunden
und sich auf etwa 41.000 erholt dieser
fiel ebenfalls um etwa 10 prozent und
liegt immer noch deutlich unter 3000
andere konz fehlen noch deutlicher
allerdings reagierte kader nun mit einem
anstieg was wirklich interessant ist ich
vermute also dass wir uns auf ein
spannendes wochenende gefasst machen
können
ich frage mich was das für andere länder
bedeutet ich meine wenn china seine
regulierungen weiter verschärft könnte
das eventuell eine chance für andere
länder darstellen
ja ich denke es herrscht noch eine art
verwirrung rund um das ganze vorgehen
der chinesischen regierung bis vor etwa
einem jahr gab es noch eine welle von
crypto befürwortern die behaupteten dass
china aufgrund des digitalen jahren
einen riesigen vorsprung bei crypto
währungen hätte
ich glaube nicht wirklich dass das
jemals der fall gewesen ist china
versucht sich seit 2003 zählern crypto
wäre es ist ein land mit strengen
devisen kontrollen und eine anlageklasse
die krypto währungen die mehr
finanzielle freiheit verspricht hat
ihnen schon immer missfallen
ich glaube nicht dass es sich hier um
einen reinen sinneswandel handelt der in
china wollte lieber crypto währung
mitmischen aber vielleicht ändert es ja
die wahrnehmung in den usa wie sie
bereits erwähnt haben könnten wir hier
china in diesem bereich einen schritt
voraus sein
vielleicht wird dieser gedanke
regulierungsbehörden zu einer
günstigeren regulierung gegenüber den
clip der unternehmen veranlassen ich
glaube nicht dass es sich hier nur um
eine erneuerung früherer aussagen und
vorschriften handelt letztlich gab es ja
auch gute nachrichten die die von
twitter
wieso stefan du hast ein bisschen
darüber gesprochen dass man mit bitkom
über deinen twitter-konto trinkgeld
geben kann
ja nun das war gestern glaube ich
ja genau ganz genau und innerhalb der
letzten zehn bis 24 stunden wurde das
aktiviert ich meine sie sprechen von
einem grundlegenden anstieg der bitcoin
nutzung richtig man könnte meinen dass
die menschen in china einen weg gefunden
haben bitkom trotz des verbotes zu
nutzen somit also nichts neues
und jetzt haben wir diese sehr bekannte
hochkarätige firma die bitcoin für einen
echten anwendungsfall einsetzt ich meine
es ist definitiv ein zuwachs des nutzt
wertes außerdem gibt es so viele
verschiedene argumente dafür dass big
count den markt wird und den mechanismus
verzerren könnte was ein neues konzept
ist das ist sehr interessant und
jetzt wieder erwähnte scheinen wir hier
etwas unterstützung zu finden und
vielleicht werden sich diese positiven
effekte durchsetzen
lea da wir gerade von anwendungsfällen
und anderen ländern sprechen ich würde
auch kurz ihre meinung zur el salvador
hören wo bitkom ja gerade als legales
zahlungsmittel eingeführt wurde ich
meine wollen länder wie china crypto
währungen tatsächlich komplett verbieten
immerhin ist bitcoin nun ein legales
zahlungsmittel eines anderen landes wie
soll das funktionieren
ja das ist in der tat sehr speziell ich
möchte aber kurz sagen stefan ich bin
auch völlig begeistert dass twitter
nicht nur eine trinkt funktion für
bitcoin eingeführt hat sondern hierfür
sogar lightning integriert hat zu deinem
punkt katie ich finde das sagt bereits
viel aus dass chinas säbelrasseln zu
einem zeitpunkt kommt in der der
internationale digitale handel an fahrt
gewinnt und salvador bleibt zu sagen das
bitcoin für illegal zu erklären
womöglich in zukunft ein problem
darstellen könnte da bitcoin nun zu
landeswährung el salvadors gehört und
geschäfte zwischen den ländern nun auch
in bitcoin abgewickelt werden können ich
denke dass nach diesem schritt als
salvadors auch andere länder
einschließlich costa rica ähnliche
schritte einleiten werden um zb bitcoin
als nationale währung akzeptieren
darunter auch länder wie die ukraine
oder über die entweder crypto
vorschriften erlassen oder signalisieren
wie im fall von panama und den usa dass
diese gesetze bald kommen werden solange
es hier funktionierende märkte und große
gewinne gibt wird es sehr schwer werden
crypto währungen auf globaler ebene zu
verbieten trotz chinas hartem
durchgreifen ist das land ein wichtiger
globaler crypto markt geblieben
chinesische crypto wollitz haben bis
heute coins im wert von rund 150
millionen dollar erhalten
somit liegt china weiterhin an zweiter
stelle nach den usa so ein bericht des
analyse anbieters chain alices henry aus
linien crypto leiter peter juesy sagte
die meisten crypto börsen in übersee
akzeptieren noch immer keine kunden aus
den usa nun müssen genau diese börsen
möglicherweise auch kunden mit sitz in
china verbieten für die meisten globalen
crypto börsen war die akzeptanz von
kunden aus china immer eine grauzone
jetzt ist diese unklarheit beseitigt
aber selbst wenn große börsen für in
china ansässige händler tabu sein
sollten sei es aufgrund der dezentralen
struktur der börsen sehr schwierig
menschen davon abzuhalten in irgendeinem
land etwas zu halten so aus linien
dpg bereitet außerdem die einführung
eines offiziellen digitalen renminbi vor
und wird damit zum vorreiter in diesem
bereich die währung soll während der
olympischen winterspiele 2022 in einem
testlauf eingeführt werden
jason terry leiter für digitale anlagen
beim vermögensverwalter system tree in
europa sagte der versuch chinas crypto
währungen zu verbieten ist nur die
fortsetzung eines trends aber sie
verschärfen die rhetorik im vorfeld der
einführung des digitalen
rendite filmpartnerin bei race capital
spricht mit emily schenk von bloomberg
technology über zukünftige strategien
für investitionen in china im zuge der
turbulenzen im land und darüber wie die
jüngste razzia langfristig eine gute
sache für das crypto ökosystem sein kann
ich bin neugierig sehen sie race capital
durch chinas verbot bedroht wie schützen
sie ihre wertanlagen
in nun ich betrachte ich ihn us markt
eher langfristig es ist natürlich schwer
täglich neue meldungen und verbote aus
china zu hören aber ich möchte alle
investorinnen noch mal daran erinnern
dass china noch immer der zweitgrößte
markt der welt ist mit über 1 4
milliarden menschen und einem
bruttoinlandsprodukt von 15 millionen
und darauf konzentriere ich mich im
venture capital bereich sehen wir uns
nur mal sekulic einer investment an sie
hat in den letzten 90 tagen 96 geschäfte
abschließen können der see ist hier also
kein abbremsen der wirtschaft zu
erkennen aber natürlich muss sich in
china nun jeder an die regeln halten
dabei spielt es keine rolle welches
unternehmen wir uns anschauen alibaba
tencent oder dede niemand kann die
chinesische regierung überlässt oder
ihre vorgaben umgehen einen kleinen
vorgeschmack der neuen chinesischen
regelungen sahen wir bei einem
unternehmen namens data cook hier wird
es sehr bald ein spac listing in der
nasdaq geben ich denke im märz
würden sie sagen dass sie ihre strategie
angesichts des harten kurses seitens
china geändert haben gehen sie ein
höheres risiko ein oder verlagern sie
ihre zahlungsströme
ich würde wirklich gerne zurück nach
china ich bin jetzt aufgrund von kogit
seit zwei jahren hier und nicht dort zu
sein macht es wirklich schwer die
investments zu kontrollieren vor allem
in der frühen phase wenn der fokus auf
support durch neue infrastruktur oder
software liegt
im moment arbeitet jeder so gut er kann
remote so dass es nicht wirklich darauf
ankommt ob man tatsächlich vor ort ist
die meisten unserer investition wurden
in letzter zeit vor allem im silicon
valley getätigt
wir haben in data briggs investiert wir
haben in ftx investiert das sind beides
global player die sowohl mit als auch
ohne china ihren geschäften nachgehen
es ist interessant dass die ft ex
erwähnen das unternehmen hat ja erst vor
kurzem seinen hauptsitz von hongkong auf
die bahamas verlegt auch zum teil wegen
dieser harten sanktionen deshalb frage
ich mich wie sich das auf lange sicht
auswirken wird ich meine denken sie die
chinesische regierung wird einige dieser
beschränkungen wieder lockern wenn dies
langfristig die strategie chinas ist wie
wirkt sich das ihrer meinung nach auf
die technologiesparte aus
ich denke die technologie-sparte muss
lernen sich an die neuen regeln zu
halten egal wie groß ein unternehmen ist
und besonders in diesem jahr ist das
gesetz zum schutz der privatsphäre von
entscheidender bedeutung
ich denke als investorin muss man sich
dessen bewusst sein
wir sollten unsere anlagestrategie nicht
allein davon abhängig machen was in
china passiert es gibt noch jede menge
potenzial weil dieser markt so gewaltig
groß ist ich glaube auch dass bestimmte
branchen eher für venture capital in
betracht kommen da man dort nicht so
viel mit sensiblen daten zu tun hat wie
etwa die bau- oder gesundheitsbranche
daher müssen gerade wir als
investorinnen einfach die augen offen
halten und schauen was in china passiert
aber was ist insbesondere mit crypto
währungen ich meine wie sie wissen ist
der handel sowie das mining in china
illegal ist der krypto sektor denn nicht
viel stärker durch das harte
durchgreifen betroffen wie wird sich das
auf ihre investitionen aus china
und crypto währungen das war schon immer
eine art hassliebe
2008 war china noch die nummer eins der
krypto industrie und führte das crypto
mining und den crypto handel an
2017 kam dann das tableau
2018 an das verbot zum tausch von vier
zu kripo finance wurde dann 2009 zehnter
crypto handel verboten bis schließlich
dieses jahr das crypto mining und der
andere generell verboten wurden was ich
damit sagen möchte ist das vom ersten
tag der restriktion der preis für
bitcoin um etwa 3000 dollar gefallen ist
laut crm gekko liegt der preis für
bitcoin aktuell bei etwa 60.000
ich denke dass das harte durchgreifen
und chinas gegen crypto währungen in
gewisser weise das cryptic ökosystem
wieder ins gleichgewicht bringt und
langfristig gesehen eine gute sache für
das blog channel system ist
[Musik]
im nachhinein wird deutlich wie resolut
china gegen bitcoin und andere crypto
währungen vorgeht während die politik
der volksrepublik in bezug auf btc in
den ersten jahren durch abwarten und
beobachten gekennzeichnet war scheint
sich die ablehnende haltung aufgrund
zunehmender popularität von crypto immer
mehr zu manifestieren
zahlreiche quellen verweisen darauf dass
dies mit der bekämpfung einer möglichen
kapitalflucht zu tun haben könnte
darüber hinaus ist seit langem bekannt
dass china an einer eigenen digitalen
währung arbeitet die zentral in den
händen der behörden liegt und im prinzip
wie herkömmliches fiat geld
funktionieren soll nur eben elektronisch
wie die nachrichtenagentur dpa berichtet
ist der digitale führen in seiner
entwicklung weit fortgeschritten und
wird bereits in einigen bereichen
eingesetzt es ist daher nicht
verwunderlich dass die chinesische
regierung alles daran setzt die krypto
konkurrenz zu verbieten
auch während der korona pandemie
wiederholte die chinesische regierung
ihre ablehnung von bitcoin und anderen
crypto währungen und ging härter gegen
illegale crypto aktivitäten vor dabei
führte sie stets den kampf gegen betrug
und geldwäsche als grund für das
vehemente vorgehen an immer mehr
ausländische websites wurden von crypto
börsen blockiert um inländische anleger
innen vom handel mit crypto währungen
abzuhalten und sie so vor den risiken
des unregulierten handels mit cyber
währung zu schützen
im mai 2021 bekräftigte die chinesische
regierung ihre absicht hart gegen das
mining von crypto währungen vorzugehen
seitdem haben zahlreiche bitcoin mining
unternehmen beschlossen das land der
mitte zu verlassen und sich in anderen
ländern wie zum beispiel in den usa
niederzulassen vor einigen monaten wurde
das ursprüngliche cyber thema wieder
aufgegriffen als die people's bank of
china alle transaktionen im zusammenhang
mit crypto währungen als illegal
erklärte
auch wenn die krypto währungen auf jedes
hier beschriebene ereignis stets mit
starken kursschwankungen reagieren
scheint der aufwärtstrend von bitcoin
ungebrochen zu sein es bleibt abzuwarten
ob dies auch weiterhin der fall sein
wird
[Musik]